this is a production of cornell
university
so i'm ben gutierrez i am the geneticist
and curator of the apple and tart cherry
collection with the plant genetics
resources unit and so we are part of the
united states department of agriculture
program of the national plant
germplasm system and that's a mouthful
but we are a site dedicated to crop
conservation and so we are one of 20
sites i tend to think we have the more
glamorous crops so we have um you might
have seen some of the seed crops from
our other curators on site but so we
have the clonal crops
here right so we're here standing in the
tart cherry collection which is more of
a minor crop
in in terms of the the size of our
collection so we have about 142
active tart cherry accessions and so
tart cherry is interesting because it's
it's not you know uh it's not a sweet
cherry right it's its own unique thing
it's a actually a tetraploid hybrid
of a sweet cherry with a wild european
dwarf cherry and there are some
interesting properties that come out so
a lot of nutritional value and
definitely a unique eating experience
but we're standing in front of one of
cornell's varieties called surefire and
i think by the fruit load that you can
see it's aptly named so if we were to
compare the tree right next to me
you can see definitely a different in
crop crop load and so this one tends to
bloom much later than some of the other
cherries in the collection which again
it's going to avoid a lot of the frost
damage or you know potential damage due
to the kind of volatile new york springs
and so
highlighting this tree again this is
montmorency one of the
really dominant cultivars grown in the
united states and so this does tend to
take a lot of damage in our in our
collection every year just due to frost
and that early spring warm and then
quickly freeze
and so i always highlight this
particular accession when we start
talking about diversity and its value
because imagine a whole crop production
based on this succession or this
particular cultivar you can see how
quickly you can lose
you know an entire crop just due to
climate conditions or other conditions
that we can't control
so really genetic diversity is
really lacking in the u.s tart cherry
industry and that's not for lack of
access to material so our tart cherry
collection comes primarily from michigan
state from uh dr amy ayazoni who was the
tart cherry and rootstock breeder there
so she did a lot of explorations
throughout europe to bring back a lot of
this material which is the the majority
of our collection so i've got some
show and tell here so this is a
hungarian variety
which ripens you know several weeks
earlier than even montmorency
in the united states but i mean you're
going to see
you know super this beautiful large
fruit and a delicious
um flavor as well
and then we still have
some of the accessions are you know
weeks behind so these still have a ways
to go in terms of fruit expansion and
ripening so each
each two trees is unique in our
collection again contrasted with an
orchard system where every cultivar
might be the same a kind of a
a model crop there but you can see just
the beautiful
crop load on on this particular
accession that's really weighing down
the branches
again it it looks ideal and maybe i get
we get a lot of criticism well why
aren't growers growing this well it it
might not match up to to what the
industry is looking for so mechanical
harvesting uniformity and just you know
whatever the the market really demands
so most of the tart cherry industry in
the us is dedicated towards you know
processing or you know some other
application not necessarily fresh eating
which i i hope will change because there
are some delicious tart cherries here
that i think would do well in the in a
fresh market
so one of the challenges of maintaining
a clonal diversity collection is of most
of our collections are maintained in the
field which means they are susceptible
to disease to the elements um
we lose lots of branches just due to
heavy winds that hit the collection on
these two particular
you know trees are really struggling
with the disease that makes them already
weak and vulnerable
and the challenge is again like the only
way really to maintain the diversity is
to to clonally propagate it
and so tart cherries don't do very well
in cryo preservation where we can store
bud material in liquid nitrogen kind of
in a safe
you know out of the environmental
conditions
and so that that really does make us
rely more heavily on these field
you know collections which again there's
really no easy way to replace some of
these cultivars if they're lost or to
disease or to the environment
so we mentioned that that tart cherry is
a tetraploid hybrid so this is the
european dwarf cherry
prunus fruiticosa
you can see a very distinctive dwarf
habit small fruit and
you know
yeah not all that desirable fruit
quality you can actually go back to the
the sweet cherry and do a tart cherry
sweet cherry hybrid and that's becomes a
duke cherry
so this is a hungarian land race
that dr iazoni brought back
and just amazing fruit tart cherry has a
really distinctive soft fruit texture in
contrast to the sweet cherry
i prefer it a lot of
you know my colleagues just don't and so
the taste preference for for tart cherry
or for cherries in general it tends to
be on the more crunchy side in north
america
certainly um
with the growing and the you know kind
of
world view and all the pallets that were
you know exposed to in the the u.s
market certainly we can
i think there's a place for more
diversity and crop and flavors and
textures and hopefully in the future
so really you need to be in here you
need to come visit the collection
because it's really difficult to talk
about easier for you to just walk
through and see and this really is kind
of mind-boggling when we're used to
you know
horticultural or
orchard systems where uniformity is is
paramount right we want
precision in agriculture we're kind of
dealing with all of the genetics some
sometimes it's kind of messy so in terms
of things bloom a different time the
spray application disease resistance
it's it's a challenge for us
all right so we are standing in the
united states department of agriculture
apple diversity collection and it is
really a world premiere collection one
of the largest and most genetically
diverse
of its kind so
um we typically have about five thousand
to six thousand seedlings or trees on
site and we also have a large seed
storage of malice wild species in a seed
vault um preserved at minus 20 celsius
but again the challenge with with clonal
conservation is that we do need to keep
trees in the field for evaluation for
access
to the germplasm so really as a curator
we we really do need to balance
accessibility and vulnerability of the
genetic resources um so we are standing
here here in a
the what we call the core diversity
collection of the apple which is 250
distinct accessions that represent the
diversity of the entire apple collection
so here we have lots of common or
popular cultivars some developed here at
cornell including empire and john of
gold
and then we have a lot of wild material
and so
one of the big things that when students
or visitors come to see us they they
look at some of these small fruited
trees and they say what's what's the
value
well apple is is unique in that all
species are
you know you can do inter-crossing or
inter-hybridization
to bring in some of the the interesting
or novel traits
of the wild relatives into a
domesticated background and that is
really important when you start thinking
about disease resistance or
climate adaptations and it's the overall
goal right is to increase
sustainability of our crop production
and that does genetics plays a really
large role in that effort to promote
sustainability so we're thinking fewer
pesticides easier maintenance easier
harvesting and those traits can be mined
from diversity collection like ours
and so typically this is our our largest
and most popular collection and we we do
receive a lot of requests for materials
so it's a free service um that we offer
to researchers and our commercial
partners um and they typically request
cyan material so that they can propagate
the the material for them for their own
but we also do fruit requests and people
characterize or they request pollen for
their own breeding purposes but we are a
collection that's not only here and
maintained but utilized and that's you
know the most important aspect i think
of our of our effort i mean what's
what's the point of keeping things if
breeders or researchers aren't going to
use them
and so we typically you know fulfill
about 500 requests and send out about 5
000 units from our collection annually
and that that number just seems to be
going and that higher and higher and
that's a an excellent indication of our
value to our stakeholders so the apple
collection is unique in that we have one
of the best backup systems in cryo
using cryopreservation and so we do lose
a lot of our
trees just primarily due to fire blight
and so having that backup and i know
typically one of the points i always try
to make is that cryo preservation isn't
just end of the world scenarios we
heavily rely annually on receiving that
material from backup i mean part of the
the challenge of maintaining diversity
collection is dealing with diversity of
susceptibility and and vulnerability to
these diseases or environmental
conditions and so
it's about 60 to 70 percent backed up in
cryo preservation so it is a little bit
early in the season so it is you know
there is tremendous diversity and just
the the the way that the trees look and
the their shapes and you can see
some of the indications of fruit but
here is one that's
particularly interesting this is called
robert's crab and this has a novel
red flesh to it i mean this you can't
even see any white by the end of the
season it's just pure red but again i
think novelty and horticultural breeding
is is the future
and so your these new
varieties that come out have to compete
with you know not just other apples but
you know all fruits from all over the
world as we you know the markets are
kind of flooded with more exotic fruits
and so here's an apple that has you know
not only a beautiful red deep red on the
outside
but it accumulates anthocyanin on the
inside so kind of a novel eating
experience
this is robert's crab really starchy
kind of a terrible flavor but i think
within a few generations of breeding and
certain cultivars have come out red
flesh that are you know much better in
terms of dessert or eating quality so
during the the initial founding of the
collection in 1983 the the collection
really was heavily focused on acquiring
cultivars and pre-breeding material and
then we saw this transition over to
collecting crop wild relatives and so
one of the most you know important crop
wild what relatives is the progenitor
species malice ceversii and so phil
forslyn the the first apple curator um
organized an exploration with herb
aldwinkle from cornell university to go
to kazakhstan to collect apples from the
the origin and so apple really is a
unique
crop in the u.s because we do we claim
it as our own but really it's quite an
exotic fruit so its origin was from
kazakhstan
and it was traded through the the silk
route into europe we're hybridized with
another species mal silvestris a
european crab apple so with malice
severity typically you'll see
a little bit larger fruit similar to the
cultivated apple
but it's lacking that acidic punch that
you really that consumers really want
so that's where so it's got sweetness
and size
and then the european malasavi has that
high acidity and so you combine the two
and you get this beautiful
you know
contrasting flavors
and so from there we get this
hybridization effect that led to what we
know as the modern domesticated apple
and certainly there has been some
selection
for for fruit size and sweetness and
acidity but really um apple in its in
its roots and its genetic diversity is
still quite untamed and so there's a lot
of potential that we still find in a lot
of
allelic and genetic diversity that's
still really untapped looking at the
pool of domesticated cultivars as well
as the crop wild relatives so we've
learned a lot about apple domestication
and its um evolution by looking at its
progenitor malice cersei and so we have
one of the one of the elite collections
premier collections of malice versi in
the world and kind of a
coming full circle was uh just over the
recent years collaborators from
kazakhstan have been requesting the
material to come back to their country
so we have a repatriation
act or activities that we're trying to
do to help them reintroduce their
heritage apple there
so some of it is um you know so some of
the diversity of mouse of rci is
endangered in its in its origin so a lot
of deforestation or other activities
causes loss of that genetic diversity
another challenge for wild apple is um
is admixture is that hybridization or
cross-pollination with cultivated apple
so a lot of the times we we go out and
explore for wild apples only to find
that they've already been hybridized by
by commercial or cultivated blocks which
is a challenge we want we want as pure
wild as we can so we can understand the
the
you know the unique attributes of a
particular species
so our effort yeah largely to support
our kazakh colleagues is to help them
reclaim their the material and
reintroduce um kind of prevent the
any future loss of malice of rci
we're standing at golden delicious which
maybe again at this early stage isn't as
recognizable but this is one of the most
important cultivars in modern breeding
programs so
you know pedigrees and genetic studies
really show us that
modern programs really have relied
heavily on about 15 accessions or 15
cultivars
in apple improvement which is kind of
scary right like we look at the full
diversity of apple and here we've been
using a really you know narrow genetic
base
for improvement and i we do see that
changing a lot with introgression of
wild species and um again genomic
selection and genomic resources really
do help us better leverage wild and more
diverse apple genetic resources
this one again does have a a unique
story when it was first developed by
starks brothers they put it in a cage
you know they found this novel tree that
they saw potential in and they didn't
want anyone else stealing it so they
erected a steel cage around it so people
couldn't steal
um the germplasm and that really i mean
as breeders and as this group right we
we really do you know want to safeguard
what we have right and but we have a
kind of an opposite mission to really
share this material with the world we
want more people to have access to our
genetic diversity so that breeders can
make their advance you know selections
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu